what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I've been sitting here thinking
cuz everybody's cranking out Watchmen
videos right now Doomsday Clock starts
tomorrow so it doesn't surprise me
everybody's doing this but I've been
sitting here thinking for like the last
couple you know really like the last
couple weeks who can defeat dr.
Manhattan and I've been thinking about
this ever since the button right because
like the button was the first time that
we really seem to get this full-on
display of dr. Manhattan's powers if you
guys never saw the button or never read
the button I've got the video down in
the description I highly suggest you buy
it it's an amazing story but it was
basically this idea where like
reverse-flash eobard thawne the
arch-nemesis of the flash Barry Allen
shows up and basically says hey look
I've discovered this absolute power and
I'm gonna tap into it I'm gonna use it
for my own and I'm finally gonna defeat
you flash and then reverse flash is
totally overwhelmed by the power he
comes across which is basically dr.
Manhattan and is incinerated in the
process this leads to the whole
investigation of the button you know
that is to say the button of the
comedian that showed up in DC rebirth
issue number one the one shot that
basically kind of reshuffled everything
and that that really set us as readers
on the path of oh my god the Watchmen
are in the DC Universe god I'm so
excited by this so like at that point it
was like okay so like if Manhattan was
powerful enough to destroy eobard thawne
basically a villain that like the flash
has the hard tongue against then what
does that mean for the other superhero
so we said okay well you know there's
Superman there's Wonder Woman there's a
lot of heroes out there that are really
really capable most anybody would sit
down and say no way Superman stands a
chance against dr. Manhattan but it is
kind of a cool discussion a cool debate
to have
but this flash-forwards you know over to
to like the Oz effect right like we just
finished doing the Oz effect and it's
basically where you learn that mr. Oz
this guy who'd kind of been operating
behind the scenes what Superman's father
who'd survived the destruction of
Krypton because he'd been yanked away by
dr. Manhattan at the moment that Krypton
was going to be destroyed and then in
turn he was subjected to like the worst
aspects of humanity basically shown all
these terrible situations with people
and so on and so forth but eventually
the Superman comes to terms with his dad
his dad's about to spill the beans on
everything that's gonna happen and
Manhattan Yanks him just just Yanks him
away just takes him away from Superman
and so then you're just kind of like
okay so Superman tries to push his way
through the energy barrier that dr.
Manhattan puts up and Superman can't get
through it and so it's just like okay so
like Manhattan is working behind the
scenes moving all these little pieces
around and just kind of experiment
with people whatever is going on and
it's weird because it's like you're
trying to figure out what role he plays
but every single step of the way when
the Earth's superheroes encounter him
they can't stop him they can't even get
to him the energy he puts off is more
than they can get past maybe the
presence who's basically the god of the
DC Universe the presence might be able
to stand chance against dr. Manhattan
I'm not really sure so so okay so here's
the deal all right here's what here's
we're gonna do we're gonna put the power
of Manhattan on display we're gonna put
this power on display and we're gonna
answer the question can anybody to feed
him and the answer is actually gonna
surprise the heck out of you guys so the
timeline of DC are the timeline of
everything from new 52 in 2011 when DC
said we want you to act like we've never
published a story before all the way up
until right now this timeline followed
like this so Barry Allen was sitting at
home one day I mean presumably he was
sitting at home one day and he's like
you know what I should save the mother
the life of my mom so Barry Allen races
back into the past stops reverse-flash
from killing his mom what ends up
happening is it creates a chain of
events the chain of events that this
creates is a whole new universe so if
the main DC Universe goes away and it's
replaced by the flashpoint universe and
the flashpoint universe everything bad
that can happen has happened Bruce Wayne
was shot by Joe Chill instead of Thomas
and Martha Wayne Martha Wayne became the
Joker Thomas Wayne became Batman and he
was ruthless
cyborg worked for the federal government
Superman was never discovered by John
and Martha Kent instead he was found by
the federal government who kept him in
like a room full of red solar radiation
and his powers never emerged
it wasn't until like flash and everybody
discovered him who they basically
released him and he went out and you
know had solar got the solar radiation
and then came back and was like okay now
we're ready to fight Wonder Woman and
the Atlanteans were at war with one
another I mean there were all kinds of
things that were going on it was like
the worst case scenario and in the
middle of all this reverse flash shows
up into in a spray he's like man look
what you did it's one of the coolest
moments in the whole story and we find
out that Barry Allen didn't remember
going back and saving his mom's life but
when he did he created this whole
universe and so Barry's response is okay
well then I have to just let my mom die
so Barry Allen goes back and he lets his
mom die now this is where dr. Manhattan
steps in at least I'm presuming this is
where Manhattan steps in we don't know
how the Watchmen got into the DC
Universe presumably it could be done as
a result of the events of Flashpoint
that for whatever reason Don you know
dr. Manhattan the Watchmen they all
showed up there everybody except for
were shot because he
in the first Watchmen comic Manhattan
immediately looked around and was just
like do this is crazy
like old like Superman you know the
concept of Superman is a comic book
superhero existed in the Watchmen
universe because the Watchmen was
designed to be the real world in a lot
of different ways and so of Manhattan
shows up in the main DC Universe and
looks around and says oh my god
Superman's real I wonder how much
control I have here well then when Barry
Allen goes back and blesses mom die
where things were supposed to go back to
normal
Manhattan steps in uh says nope now ten
years has gone from everybody's life
nobody remembers who they were before
and they're all basically acting like
their new superheroes for the very first
time to have that kind of power it's
crazy because you're talking about like
reality manipulation you're talking
about altering the minds of people of
all beings everywhere because remember
when it came to like the whole DC
landscape we're not just talking about
Batman and Superman and Wonder Woman in
the flashing Green Lantern we're talking
about everything vertigo which means
like Constantine Lucifer Morningstar the
presence we're talking about all these
things have all had their minds wiped or
presumably wiped and basically had ten
years of their lives removed by
Manhattan and so it's just like okay
this is getting kind of crazy because
this is an insane level of power and if
that's the kind of power we're talking
about if we're talking about power
that's above the most powerful beings
that we've ever seen then what chance
does anybody have to stop him well okay
run over the roster for a second that
man nope I don't care what the Batman
fans say prep times not gonna help you
here when it comes to Wonder Woman not a
chance the flash no way if he's not on
land he can't do anything the Green
Lantern probably not he's powerful but
he's not that powerful the white Lantern
the white Lantern of life not a chance
how do we know because Kyle Rayner is
the White Lantern Hal Jordan the Green
Lantern Corps tried to bring the white
Lantern's back not only to have dr.
Manhattan keep that from happening but
to in turn break the white Lantern ring
of Kyle Rayner he basically overpowered
the white Lantern and shattered his ring
and destroyed any chance of the white
lanterns coming back so okay that's out
the window like Superman no way Superman
has a chance going toe-to-toe against
against dr. Manhattan nowhere near the
chance of going against that guy and so
that brings into the equation the
question of who has a chance I mean
those are some of the most powerful
beings
Superman is by and large considered to
be one of the most powerful beings on
earth if not the most powerful being now
there's other characters that we haven't
seen yet Martian Manhunter Shazam
different things like that but again
Shazaam has always been the equal of
Superman when he was originally created
by you know Bill Parker and CC Beck he
was designed to be a carbon copy of
Superman except that it was a little kid
who shot a Shazam and basically became
Superman he was a backup feature in
Justice League in new 52 but he's always
been a really really really powerful
character on par with Superman and so my
argument is this if Superman can't win
no way show Sam can win so that asks the
question who do I think could beat dr.
Manhattan the person and you guys are
are you guys are so this is gonna be a
very polarizing response the person that
I think can defeat dr. Manhattan is a
woman by the name of Cameron chase now I
imagine a lot of people are just like
who who in the world is Cameron chase
unless you're reading Supergirl you
probably have no idea who this girl is
Kim and Chase is just some government
crony she works for the Department of
extra-normal operations there's nothing
special about her except for the fact
that she can shut down the powers of
other people that's one of the coolest
things out there Jimmy that's the only
way you can win right this it's the only
way you can beat Manhattan is to
basically shut down his powers and
that's it that's the only way to really
stop I mean I guess if you had like a
time traveler who went all the way into
the past of you know dr. Manhattan and
stopped him before the whole you know
electron collider experimenting when
wrong and he basically gained his powers
I guess you could do that but time
travel seems like it would be a cheap
way to stop it right like DC doesn't
really use time travel in that regard
like that's more of a Marvel thing and
like who else can you have that would
make a compelling story if you have
Superman who's basically defeated by dr.
Manhattan Manhattan shows up the Justice
League gets shut down you have AI all
these guys just getting wrecked left and
right Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam and then
you just have this lowly de Oh agent who
comes strolling into the picture and
suddenly Manhattan's powers don't work
he's just a blue naked guy who can't do
anything he does these just like a
weirdo didn't like that would be amazing
to me because it would be the change
that you never expect you kind of
expected it with like Superman versus
documen Hatton and I mean Jeff John's a
guy who's Jesus in DC what if he comes
along and he says okay we're gonna craft
this story with some measure of realism
tied into it then nobody would really
believe that Superman would win I mean
you would expect him to just keep
fighting and fighting and fighting until
he more or less just realizes there's
nothing he can do and then maybe
would be like Batman who had grabbed
hammer and chasing this be like yo we
need your help and just like take her
and whisk her over to Manhattan because
the kicker about Cameron chases powers
is that they only work when she feels
threatened is more like a subconscious
thing it's not something that she
controls you know willingly it's just
kind of something that happens
automatically and so it's kind of cool
because if she's in the vicinity of
Manhattan who's just like wrecking
everybody and she's like yep and your
powers are gone now so Superman do what
you want to do the question is what
happens when his powers come back that
would be the question I asked cuz man
man that'd be crazy thing I mean if I
were Cameron chase I would be like man
look I'm not gonna take the man's powers
away because like what his powers come
back baby's gonna be mad at you things
are gonna be bad things are gonna be
rough for you guys I don't know but to
me that's the question I've been asking
me for really for true removing Cameron
chase in the equation I cannot think of
a singular person within the realm of DC
who would be able to go toe-to-toe
against dr. Manhattan and successfully
defeat him we could speculate I mean
there are characters like The Spectre
maybe the presence possibly you know I
mean there's characters out there where
we could kind of maybe think they could
just because of their position within
the hierarchy of the DC Universe but
that's all we have the only legitimate
argument you can make about why the
presence would win against dr. Manhattan
is because well he's God and in the DC
Universe and and I mean you know
nobody's higher than God I mean that's
true until until somebody is and that's
even one of the crazy things is because
you know with the presence for the whole
idea behind him is he's sure God in the
DC multiverse but one of the big
questions that people ask is the
conundrum of like the God of Abraham who
made him where did he come from and even
if you go back and you read like Grant
Morrison's whole idea like the crazy
craziness of Multiversity you know and
the whole idea Final Crisis and the
origin of the multiverse is so on and so
forth the presence was not that being
that created the multiverse we don't
know what it was to create of the
multiverse the multiverse came into
existence the whole role of the presence
was to basically set life in motion to
begin the process is just moving life in
a forward direction so that life would
begin evolving and growing and so then
you could turn around and grab the
concept of Manhattan and say well he's
the one that created everything he's the
one that created the DC multiverse and
he created the presents I mean there's
so many things that could come out of
this and it's almost mind-boggling
because the whole point of DC rebirth is
to basically be a reshuffling right new
52 comes along and says hey look we want
you to pretend like we've never
published a story before we've never
made anything about Superman in the
flash or Green Lantern or Wonder Woman
we want you to treat these characters
like they're
new to the world d.c rebirth comes back
and says yeah I mean do that except add
these few things in and so again it's
kind of cool in terms of how it works
and how it unfolds but on the concept of
dr. Manhattan I don't know who can be -
maybe you guys do I mean Wren I've been
reading Marvel Comics for over 20 years
I've been reading DC for like three so
let me know let me know like those of
you guys who were really experienced in
DC Comics let me know what you guys
think about like who it is that can beat
Manhattan I'm really curious who it is
that you guys can come up with it aside
from Cameron chase you can just kind of
shut down his powers I don't know
anybody else and like we even sit with
her she can shut down his powers
temporarily but his powers will come
back as soon as he you know as soon as
he's out of her cool little sphere of
influence whatever it is so you know
once she's out of the picture his powers
flare back up again who's gonna be able
to defeat it I don't know I mean it's
crazy it's interesting to me man I love
this kind of stuff let me know I'm so
excited about Doomsday Clock
I am so hyped for Doomsday Clock I think
man it's we saw the ashcan when we were
at a New York Comic Con we got to go to
the press conference thing that like
Geoff Johns was putting on and it was
super cool the whole panel he was
hosting where he was answering questions
I was so disappointed because I got up
there there was a person in front of me
they got their question answered and
then I was like well guys we're out of
time and I'm like no I was so
disappointed I was so sad I was just
like man I was so close I was this close
to having my question answered by geoff
johns
i was so sad but anyway we've kind of
ranted long enough let me know what you
guys think about who it is it could
actually defeat dr. Manhattan I'm kind
of curious let me know what you guys
think about that about that whole thing
because I mean I know a lot of you guys
have been reading DC a lot longer than I
have I mean a lot of you guys have
knowledge on DC Comics that would that
just blow me out of the water no
questions asked I don't care how obscure
it is pull it out and throw it in the
comment section because I'm curious to
see what all you guys come up with but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain and make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]